hey wisecrack timing can be weird when
we started working on this video about V
for Vendetta we really didn't expect its
release to feel so eerily timely the
film is obviously not a perfect or even
close metaphor for this moment v the
leader of the protest movement depicted
in the film is extravagantly violent in
real life overwhelmingly peaceful
protests continue in the wake of the
brutal murder of George Floyd by the
police we hope that you're making your
voice heard we also hope that you're
able to do so safely and that you take
care of your mental health during this
difficult time thanks guys
hey wisecrack jared here today we're
talking about the vaudevillian veteran
cast vicariously as both victim and
villain by the vicissitudes of fate it's
V for Vendetta the film based on the
graphic novel of the same name was met
with generally positive reviews and
relative box-office success but the
graphic novels curmudgeonly creator Alan
Moore was left unimpressed by
Hollywood's translation of his work
describing the film as a defanged
version of the original so is Alan Moore
right or just very grumpy at Detective
Comics let's find out in this wisecrack
edition on V for Vendetta deep or dumb
and of course spoilers ahead for the
film and the graphic novel our guys
let's do a quick recap we start out with
a news monologue delivered by the voice
of London Lewis Protheroe who explains
the current state of affairs a
mysterious plague has spread across the
world turning the United States into a
leper colony and now 20 years later is
one the world's biggest mecha colony and
provoking radical changes in Britain led
by dictator Adam sutler the far-right
Norse fire party has transformed Britain
into a police state that runs on
complete obedience and conformity while
a combination of state propaganda and
secret police managed to keep most of
the country compliant with the sutlers
authoritarian regime one man rises up to
oppose it VIII the film follows VIII and
his Ward's /not totally consensual
mentee evey Hammond sv blows up symbols
of British law and assassinates party
members who have wronged him but these
final masterpiece is a revolution itself
as is very calculated acts of terror
inspired the masses to rise up against
their fascist
let's first start with what the film and
graphic novel have in common
these fixation on symbols whether he's
talking to Lady Justice blowing up
symbols of British authority or wearing
a Guy Fawkes mask the guy seems to see
symbols as a key to cementing political
authority rather than just the violence
of jackbooted men the antidote to those
symbols our counter symbols ideas and
art as Evie reminds us to tell the truth
while politicians used them to cover the
truth up and his shadow gallery is
basically a Noah's Ark about Lawd ideas
to film even take some of this farther
as eby's friend dietrich hides a Quran
and protests art he also gets all Benny
Hill in his mocking of sutler
[Music]
even as Detrick is dragged away by the
secret police and V dies it's clear that
their ideas will outlive them but while
this conceit is plenty laudable it's not
like more or the film have really
reinvented the wheel here
maybe dramatized it well this brings us
to a small choice in the film that ends
up drastically altering its meaning as a
Norse fire party comes to power in the
movie and like many a real-life
authoritarian regime Norse fire presents
the idea of a glorious more homogeneous
past the country has lost by deviating
from traditional values Britain once had
a strong proud national identity they
claimed but it has been diluted and
polluted by modernity diversity and sin
using a swastika like red and black
symbol which includes the Christian
cross Norse fire presents itself as the
antidote to chaos sutlers motto is
strength through unity unity through
faith or strength through purity purity
through faith as it's phrased in the
graphic novel which also explicitly
linked the motto to the Roman fasces a
bundle of wood that cannot be broken
unless divided this simple forceful
slogan continually reinforces the notion
that the country is strong when everyone
lines up behind the leader and lives
according to his rules consequently
anyone who does not offer complete
obedience is an enemy of the people the
pursuit of personal freedom becomes an
attack on the very fabric of society
doubt will plunge this country back into
chaos at a glance this
anti-authoritarian tale seems like
exactly what Alan Moore would hope for
from a cinematic adaptation of his work
so what's his beef so much of Moore's
identity as an artist has revolved
around interrogating the idea of power
and how it's used particularly about the
dangers of any one person wielding great
power whether they're naked blue super
humans like dr. Manhattan or oppressive
dictators like sutler or Susan as he's
named in the book while director James
McTeague adaptation holds true to the
rejection of authoritarianism the issue
more found was that it makes it all too
simple the film's world is separated so
clearly into evil tyrants and virtuous
rebels that much of the graphic novels
nuance is lost Moors V for Vendetta was
not a clear-cut case of good against
evil but a battle between
authoritarianism and anarchism
by contrast the movie is just Authority
versus honest people that brings us to
Norse fires rise to power in the graphic
novel a global nuclear war between the
Soviet Union and the United States in
the 80s has reduced much of the world to
an irradiated wasteland Britain is
spared by the war but finds itself in a
state of crisis afterwards when the
resulting nuclear winter causes a famine
out of the chaos that follows the Norse
fire party rises to power in the movie
however a viral pandemic rather than a
nuclear war lays the groundwork this new
plague kills thousands in Britain and is
reported to have all but destroyed the
u.s. as in the book a crisis creates
opportunity and the Norse fire party is
able to seize control at first glance
this might seem like a superficial
change the point in either case is that
a period of global turmoil creates
widespread panic and desperation leading
the British public to turn to a zealot
like sutler fear followed by apathy has
allowed the country to fall under the
spell of a right-wing strongman as he
explains
and a new panic you turn to the now High
Chancellor Adam sutler
however it's later revealed that the
virus which ravaged Britain was in fact
intentionally released by sutler and his
cronies to force the country into
accepting their leadership imagine a
virus the most terrifying virus you can
and then imagine that you argue alone
not the cure the point is that in the
film's version of the story the British
people were essentially duped Norse fire
didn't rise to power by winning the
honest support of the masses but by
fooling them contrast that with the
graphic novel in which the wars that
devastated the world were real many the
problems were real and the public was
all too willing to turn towards fascism
racism and homophobia V for Vendetta was
born out of mores own experience of life
under someone whom he considered to be a
hard right zealot Margaret Thatcher
having watched the Iron Lady win the
support of his countrymen Moore was
under no illusions as to how popular
these politics could be the film however
makes the populace significantly less
blameworthy the people are basically
good
turning a three-book graphic novel
series into a two-hour movie was always
going to require some streamlining so we
can't really blame them for cutting out
some of the fascist propaganda or entire
scenes but far more concerning the movie
arguably loses the moral ambiguity of
the graphic novel in Moore's telling the
government official
to send people to concentration camps
are also people with families desires
ambitions jealousies etc they're
three-dimensional
in contrast the film reduces Norse fire
to a cabal of cartoonish villains in a
dark room simplifying the moral and
political implications of the story
fittingly the movie shows sutler mostly
as a Big Brother esque ominous talking
head rendering him literally
two-dimensional he's no longer the
complex weirdo who falls in love with a
computer from Alan Moore's version the
film's message becomes this there's a
small set of clear bad men amongst a sea
of good people all it takes is one brave
hero to help overthrow them and things
can be set right again in the graphic
novel the Norse fire members are of
course still awful but they're at least
presented as fully rounded human beings
ranging from true believers in Norse
fire xenophobic Creed to those who are
just following orders
the graphic novel actually takes pains
to show us the private lives of these
Norse fire members people who go to
church and raise families and goof
around at work the point of course is
not to say that these are good people
within this fascist organization just
that they are people reducing them to
comic book bad guys might be more
comfortable for the viewer but it shiz
away from their reality and just as
Norse fire leaders have been exaggerated
into one no bad guys V Himself is
noticeably softened and simplified for
the big screen in the movie V is an egg
frying slow dancing charmer with a love
of romantic movies and Shakespearean
plays he kills in cold blood it's true
but his victims are so outlandish ly
awful but this never seems like too much
of a moral compromise the movie may
claim that the monstrous things that
were done to him turned V into a monster
but that's not really what we see in the
graphic novel however v is considerably
less dashing the mask he wears isn't
just to cover his scars hide his
identity or create a symbol the static
unfeeling face it presents is a
representation of who V is trying to
become and the guy Foxe grimace sneaks
its way into panels of Norse fire
members suggesting V's method isn't so
far removed from the people he wants to
destroy because his victims aren't all
painted as cartoonish villains were
forced to reckon with the extreme cost
of political violence like sutler he's
ultimately a man so convinced of his own
ideology that he'll do whatever it takes
in pursuit of it so what we have
is not a battle between forces of pure
good and pure evil but between a
proponent of authoritarianism and an
agent of Anarchy so let's talk about
anarchy
perhaps the biggest change to these
character lies and what he actually
wants at the beginning of the movie
before the Old Bailey courthouse
explodes he delivers a speech which
outlines exactly what he hopes to
achieve wait it is to Madam Justice that
I dedicate this content Oh in honor of
the holiday she seems to have taken from
these parts and in recognition of the
imposter that stands in her stead vie
turns himself and specifically his mask
into a symbol of true incorruptible
justice in doing so he hopes to remind
people that such a thing can still exist
if they come together and fight for it
he tips his hat to the Statue of Lady
Justice as he does so acknowledging both
what she stands for and how those values
have been corrupted by settlers brutal
and dishonest regime ultimately he is
pledging loyalty to the concept of
justice itself the v of the graphic
novel also has a conversation with Lady
Justice but it plays out quite
differently he begins by making a formal
introduction between the two of them
while voicing both roles this might
suggest that he's not quite so mentally
composed as his on-screen counterpart
from the start their conversation is
filled with odd sexual undertones
framing Lady Justice as v's childhood
crush things then quickly turn nasty as
Vee accuses her of cheating on him with
Norse fires leader painting himself as a
jilted lover where they scored a settle
v is established here not as a noble
freedom fighter coming to the nation's
rescue but is a deeply damaged man with
a thirst for vengeance that borders on
the erotic perhaps what is most telling
about the scene is that it echos an
earlier moment in which Norse fires
leader outlines his racially pure vision
for Britain's future and explains his
belief in fascism just like with these
conversation what begins as a statement
of political ideology quickly descends
into an angry personal diatribe with
unsettling sexual undercurrent after
lamenting the fact that he's never been
with a woman in real life
Susan moves on to personifying his
political ideal of fate as a woman he is
in love with just as V does with Lady
Justice
while V and sutler are polar opposites
in the film the novel uses these scenes
to draw an eerie parallel both men are
driven by personal grudges and Prime
desires what's most significant though
is how the conversation between V and
Lady Justice ends with V cutting ties to
Liberty and pledging allegiance to
anarchy instead he talks about his dream
of turning Britain into the land of do
as you please the name taken from a
children's story by Enid Blyton in his
view the complete obliteration of
government and law will allow everyone
the freedom to live their lives however
they see fit the dangers of anarchism
are not lost on more however with no
government to enforce the laws that are
in place it's also possible that we
enter a Darwinist state where those with
the greatest capacity for violence rule
over those around them although this
isn't exactly different than your life
under Norse fire v also has a term for
this the land of take what you want but
the chaos can give way to a kind of
anarchic order where people voluntarily
submit to the ideals that control their
behavior this argument is near and dear
to more a self-professed anarchist mores
V even invokes the German word for order
or Danone which evokes the system of
rules used by self-governing Amish
communities but in the film any ideas of
anarchy ultimately disappear except for
a quick allusion to a misquote of the
famous anarchist Emma Goldman repetition
without Duensing as I and a man yelling
what's important is that the graphic
novel ends with no clear answer as to
where things will go from here v is dead
and while he successfully blows up
number 10 Downing Street in one last act
of defiance it's unclear what effect
this gesture will have on the nation at
large the film's ending is much more of
a crowd-pleaser
while V still dies his final act has
clearly inspired the country around him
the sea of Guy Fawkes masks watching on
as westminster burns are proof that the
British people have woken up to the true
nature of the Norse fire party and are
ready to take back their country the bad
guys are dead the good guys one
authoritarianism as the novel
understands is not something that arises
because a small group of evildoers hatch
a plan it rises out of the country
itself championed by large sections of
the public the movie sidesteps the
difficulty of this truth to provide a
brighter breezier version of good
conquering evil ultimately the movie is
considerably less deep than the source
material but it still has enough
substance to save it from a full dumb
verdict
it cleverly depicts the way
authoritarian governments control their
citizens by manipulating the flow of
information and offers some interesting
thoughts about the power of symbols in
our society so pretty deep and maybe
important formatively if you're a
teenage Jared in the end we're left with
the same question which he poses to the
people of the UK do we want an inspiring
story about good triumphing over evil or
are we ready to take a harsh look at
where that evil comes from in the first
place let us know what you think in the
comments big thanks to our awesome
patrons for supporting us hit that
subscribe button and as always thanks
for watching guys peace
[Music]